it tends to be white people when they're
just trying to figure out what to call
you they're just like I grew up
identifying as black I identify as a
black man I think I identify and call
myself black it's because I'm still
trying to trace my ancestry I identify
as african-american identify as black
but I'm also Creole I am Asian American
and Nigerian American but I honestly I
caught myself black black is beautiful
and I've always just found strength in
the word you know black is strong black
it's pretty depending on the situation
or the moment in time I'll feel hella
proud like yeah incredibly proud to be a
black man and black power all that other
good stuff but then to society there's a
lot of like negatives of black a
synonymous with ghetto it's synonymous
with loud it's synonymous with lazy the
only time that it really bothers me is
when it's used amongst people who look
like me you know someone from the
Caribbean or someone from a country in
Africa that are saying I'm not black I'm
Nigerian or I'm not black I'm Bayesian
members of my family they want to
separate themselves from black Americans
because they think that being too tied
to that means that they're ghetto we
should be on a much stronger unified
front it's interesting for me because I
technically am African American I mean
me personally I feel like African
American is is a label that was created
for us it just seems like something that
would be in like the New York Times to
describe black people I'm not from
Africa directly so I don't feel like I
should label myself as an African
American I think for some people it just
feels wrong to harken back to something
that they now unfortunately don't really
have a connection to I sometimes refer
myself as Gani in America and just
because I mean that's what I am African
American is such is still such a wide
and broad term my family's from Haiti so
I never really tied myself to African
America there's 90 something countries
in Africa just like there are varying
types of white people there varying
types of black people I don't think
there's anything
with that term yeah I think it just
depends on where you are and finding
yourself in your ancestry it's just kind
of interesting how with time as a people
we find identity with certain words and
maybe that's the other thing is that
like how you identify with it it's just
fluid I think there's like this dough I
think if you are rejecting it in this
and out a lot of fun [ __ ] regardless of
your race and your ethnicity your
background so to speak just be proud of
who you are